salut à tous quel début de semaine
pénalité et je remarque beaucoup de gens
et des médiums ont déjà décidé qu'il
était en pole sur la vérité ultime sans
même besoin de vérifier puisque la star
l'a dit et qu'un gang et quinconque
l'ayant par là même carrière des
magistrats fermer le public c'est l'air
y accuse de trahison c'est grâce à moi
mais si de grandeur a été obligé de
s'exprimer publiquement sous peine de
personnes vous à liberté du du fait que
son petit frère que voulant mois ou en
prison
nice plutôt pas le petit fracture et
règne le frère
alors qu'elle rend faire quelques petits
frères alors le cancer tiens ça ne
mollit pas parce qu'il a refait une
vidéo il ya quelques heures là pour dire
voyez tout ce que j'annonçais est avéré
ce qui se passe c'est que paul pogba a
été entre guillemets obligé de
reconnaître devant les enquêteurs qu'il
avait un marabout voilà et épaisse
marabo pour l'empêcher d'avoir des
blessures ce qui n'a pas marché parce
que il est actuellement blessé mais
selon nos infos on les maintient il y
aurait vraiment je jean-paul
conditionnelle une vidéo dans laquelle
dans laquelle paul pogba s'adresserait
un marabout pour entre guillemets jeter
un sort à qu'il y en ait mbappé jeter un
sort ça veut dire que le marabout
fassent des sacrifices pour que mba
pêche ou moins bien alors on imagine
l'ambiance en équipe de france ce qu'il
faut dire ça arrive ça parce que moi
j'ai eu des infos oui
il m'a dit que kilian et paul se
seraient parlé et que tout irait bien
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit voilà chine de
l'info je sais pas l'adultère voilà et
parle aux enquêteurs a dit que le
marabout et est uniquement dédié à sa
proposition à lui pas qu'ils soient
blessés entre les blessures voit la rue
alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
didier deschamps a très bien entre
guillemets manoeuvrer parce qu'il a été
avisé de ça avant il a engagé devant
comme d'habitude nous la brasse il a
pris les devants pour tenter d'amortir
le choc c'est quand même deux joueurs
stars de l'équipe de france mais ce qui
se passe c'est que pogba est blessé si
cette vidéo est avéré cyril je pense que
pogba ne peut pas aller à la coupe du
monde c'est irréconciliables et il se
murmure c'est un agent de foot qui m'a
dit ça aujourd'hui il m'a dit tu verras
pogba va faire durer sa blessure et il
prête extra blessures entre guillemets
diplomatique qui lui permettra de sortir
par le haut ne pas être sanctionné et de
ne pas aller à la coupe du monde un peu
dans ce cas chez nous à quoi la tendance
aujourd'hui cette histoire les folles on
va pouvoir appeler quand même l'histoire
avant d'avoir les infos de géraldine et
et de benjamin gille parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui lisent ou comprend oui
c'est vrai question prix se sont même si
ça à la cuisson alors les gens que tu
peux rappeler à nos téléspectateurs ce
qu'on ya plein de gens qui on comprend
les états fait il ya quelques mois vers
le mois de mars porte badge ou encore à
manchester et il s'aperçoit qu'on l'a
escroquée ça tu nous l'ennemi non mais
parce que d'entrée de jeu non mais c'est
pas ça combat il ya une vidéo de
matthias kopp bah oui qui est sorti à un
moment mathias son bus qu'on aime bien
qu'on a reçu ici oui atias pour son
association pourquoi il a fait cette
vidéo à la base de mathias pour dire
qu'il avait des révélations sur son
frère oui parce que c'est là que ça
commence oui parce qu'un tiens c'est
parti ferait partie de cet entourage qui
a été écarté et donc ouais donc il a été
quart des voix la wii qui a été écarté à
l'époque et matthias katsch aurait été
proche de son frère quatre jours
assister à tous les matchs s'est senti
floué et il s'est dit mais c'est pas
possible et paul jean pas encore le
conditionnel aurait reconnu parmi des
gens qui l'ont menacé avec un fusil
d'assaut il aurait reconnu son frère sas
écoles cepal démarrer face et ça c'est
la version de paul pogba c'est la
version mais je te parle l'histoire ça
démarre d'une vidéo de vejer de huy de
paul pogba qui dit qu' il faut faire des
révélations sur son frère a créé son
compte twitter à cette occasion en août
2022 c'est sûr avant en mars quand il ya
le rassemblement à clairefontaine paul
koumba poste une photo avec son frère
parce qu'il avait créé une sorte
d'association et son très proche y dit
mon frère je t'aime pour la ville tuant
fière de toi tu vas réussir donc en mars
2001 2 tout va bien en tout cas sur les
réseaux entre les deux hommes donc à la
soeur de marabouts dont on parle et qui
a été confirmé alors reste à savoir si
oui ou non il ya un sort qui a été jetée
contre quillan m ap en revanche il ya eu
confirmation qu'il ya deux mecs qui sont
arrivés au centre d'entraînement de
turin où jouent et pumba avec un mec
qu'on voit sur on a demandé à ce que
paul kamba sorte il n'a pas voulu sortir
et c'est pour ça qu'il est allé porter
plainte et en italie et en france donc
ça a été confirmé aussi alors cette
affaire sur l'île affaire d'hommes passé
pour ce qui suit pas trop le foot c'est
un grand international français champion
du monde qui joue maintenant la juventus
de turin qui a joué à moitié terminé
titre moi j'ai moi j'ai en plus un truc
c'est que chez j'ai eu par hasard en
fait voilà paul pogba en facetime cet
été je n'existe pas tout ça et en plus
comme un coup juni tiens j'ai vu ton
frère il était dans l'émission et voilà
donc ça ça donne à saint-saud silicone
c'est vrai quoi là et donc et voilà d'y
rencontrer pour une émission placée chez
lui à manchester il avait fait un truc
top pour un jeune qui rêvait de le
rencontrer donc voilà c'est vrai que moi
j'aime bien les deux donc je suis un
petit peu tiraillé parce que c'est vrai
que mathias étaient venus aussi pour son
association ici dans l'émission il a été
extrêmement sympathique c'est un garçon
que j'aime beaucoup et paul pogba ils
nous avaient fait 1 il nous avait
accueillis à manchester c'est vrai dans
sa maison pour un jeune garçon qui
rêvait blanc mais pour une émission dont
le rêve c'est été rayé de rencontrer
paul pogba oui il me semble que russie
n'est une question de raquette et
d'extorsion de fonds dont on a parlé de
ça aussi mais ça c'est la version grohl
taux bas aux états n'a pas fait de vidéo
là tu oui non mais moi ce qui me gêne
c'est ya une sorte de lynchage sur les
réseaux sociaux contre mathias pogba les
gens préfèrent position parce que paul
pogba est un peu plus même beaucoup plus
populaires venus que son frère et c'est
assez injuste je pense qu'il faut
laisser les enquêteurs faire leur
travail on ne sait pas pourquoi mathias
pogba fait cette vidéo peut-être qu'il a
des bonnes raisons de la faire et
peut-être que c'est son dernier recours
pour se faire entendre donc laissons les
enquêteurs faire leur travail et
arrêtons de juger avant les enquêteurs
donc vous vous dites gilles que mathias
a fait cette vidéo parce que en fait ils
travaillaient que son frère oui l'été
oui il est amer d'avoir été et a été
écartée quand il a été écarté en mars
quand il ya eu quand paul pogba sa
personne qu'on la remarque il vire tout
le monde dont son frère et il se sépare
vraiment de plusieurs membres de sa
famille et l'a sacrée des clashs et il
se murmure qu'il y aurait peut-être gens
pas encore le conditionnel des affaires
d'argent derrière tout ça est ce qui
devrait de l'argent est ce que paul
devrait de l'argent à matthias s que
mathias ferait partie des gens qui l'ont
protégé pendant longtemps est lancée
voici sort de protection est ce qu'on
peut expliquer aux téléspectateurs ce
qui dans cette affaire elle intéresse
énormément elle et les français bien
entendu c'est quoi cette histoire de
protection c'est quoi ce qu'il faisait
racketter c'est quoi l'histoire alors
des gens affirme avoir protégé paul
pogba pendant 13 ans protégé c'est à
dire faire partie de son entourage
proche je veux protéger d'autres voyous
le protégé risques induits par la
fortune etc et ces gens là ont réclamé
13 millions d'euros 1 million par an à
paul pogba aux log bas à partir de mars
à verser de l'argent il l'a reconnu aux
enquêteurs il a versé de l'argent
sous-entendu si la verser de l'argent
c'est ce que dit certain c'est qu'il
reconnaît qu'il y aurait une protection
mais lui dit non mais j'ai été menacé
j'ai voulu mettre un terme à cette
menace d'où aussi le transfert à turin
ce que disent ravis il s'est dit en
allant à turin je vais être tranquille
et puis les voix de nouveaux débarqués
et l'aï dit au club de turin la juventus
c'est plus possible il porte plainte en
italie et en france il ya beaucoup
d'affaires de raquette comme ça dans le
nord le football il ya beaucoup scellier
alentours à ce qu on appelle ça le
premier entourage avec des gens souvent
c'est ces joueurs là reste fidèle aux
quartiers aux gens avec qui ils ont
grandi et ça c'est tout à fait louable
et redistribue ils font des actions mais
parfois denses et entourage il ya des
gens qui ont mal tourné et là c'est la
version de paul pogba des jambes son
entourage sont devenus des délinquants
ayant menacé on parle d'un fusil
d'assaut dans un appartement quand même
de région parisienne où ils en étaient
menacés à peu près quelle somme il
aurait donné paul pogba pour quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros c'est ce
qu'il a affirmé voilà qu'en quelques
illusions rabine pour l'instant ce sont
mille cent mille âmes d'accord sur ce
que les 13 millions il a donné 13
millions évidemment la banque ne vient
pas de nos petites coupures m'a bien sûr
à ccc sur wii c'est peut-être à lui
qu'il faut castaldi demande les 500
villes russes